the travelers out in the road is our
transportation correspondent Kris Van
Cleave he's in Boston ready to face the
Thanksgiving traffic firsthand all the
way from Boston to DC Chris are you sure
you want to do this no I feel like I
lost a bet we're doing it we we and you
know like more than 49 million other
Americans are going to crammed into
vehicles they're gonna feel way too
small by the end of the journey and
drive somewhere for Thanksgiving but
with all the weather out there
that Trek to your Thanksgiving dinner is
going to be anything but easy
giant Thanksgiving storms are pummeling
roads across the u.s. and snarling air
travel with thousands of delays and
cancellations it's busy there's delays
all over the screen rain and wind will
bear down on parts of the east and west
coasts as traffic hits its peak this
afternoon more than tripling drive times
in Atlanta New York Los Angeles Houston
and Boston people should be extra
careful Massachusetts State Police have
stepped up patrols Lieutenant Anthony
dear knows Thanksgiving means more cars
more traffic and more accidents watch
this vehicle here this white one twice
he's crossed over and jerk back I just
did it again
yes he spotted this SUV swerving on the
Massachusetts Turnpike license
registration please the driver Glenn
Holmes got a warning he was heading to
Thanksgiving in Connecticut what was
going on on the rails this is Amtrak's
busiest season college student Jada
Hines is heading to old bridge New
Jersey Boston's really hectic to get
home from Thanksgiving tsa expects a
record number of Flyers 2.7 million
today alone United Airlines CEO Oscar
muñoz says planes will be fuller in part
because of the grounded 737 max it's
gonna be crowded there are going to be
many people who are flying that don't
normally fly so a little patience a
little empathy always goes a long way
patience and empathy here is the look at
our drive it's about 440 miles between
here at Copley Square in Boston and
Washington DC now we've got the the
truck all loaded up we are going to be
going mostly down Interstate 95 which of
course is the busiest and most congested
freeway in the country and a good day it
should take seven to eight hours this
may not be a good day but we're hoping
to be there in time for the CBS Evening
News with Norah O'Donnell and we'll be
checking in on CBS n throughout the day
so you can you can see if it's a travel
dream or travel misery Chris I think you
won the bet because listen think of all
the good friends you're gonna meet along
the way think about that that's that's a
great way to look at it Gail if we're
gonna make all kinds of new friends
today yes you're welcome thank you Chris
Van Cleve